please before you leave say hello to one
or two faces you don't know that is
always historically been the real Roi
from things of this so have the courage
to say hello to somebody that you don't
know because it's a safe kind ecosystem
so thank you have a great can
I do trade attention and build
businesses
this industry is incredibly capable of
not caring about today eighty percent of
the energy is around commercials and the
other 20 is around AI meanwhile more
stuff will be sold today because of
social media ads than anything else in
the world outside of this world we talk
about social media as the most powerful
tool that is like upending governments
in this industry we don't talk about it
this is it
[Music]
most professors aren't
because they don't live in the real game
and they may not like my energy you know
and I respect that and I have a lot of
admiration for what they're trying to do
but their judgment on me isn't super
scary because I'm living in real life of
marketing and may tend to not such a
pleasure to meet you man it's so
interesting like this professors really
it makes me sad it makes me sad for the
kids yeah
[Music]
I thought you said that's the difference
of me actually getting the Hat
[Music]
I recognized cheers
I have a lot of empathy for how you guys
sure teachers are going to think about
how to make it work
[Music]
s how are you what's up my dude looking
sharp looking sharp so nice to meet you
we just have to get our industry to
recognize these truths which is brand is
built on social and this industry is
desperately trying to not accept that
and until it does it will continue to
have ankle biter take a market share and
they'll continue to spend a billion
dollars to m a a brand doing what they
could be doing but they'd much rather
waste money on dumb
[Music]
thank you you did a great job up there
you can't just harness something and
then slap a brand on it because it went
viral and it's going to sell you more
things if it's not on brand then it
can't work consumer smells but who
decides what's on brand bad advertising
makes people get away from the platform
people want relevance and this on brand
talk is killing us because we're in
boardrooms debating on brand and then
the brand manager changes and snarky is
different to you than to her right so I
think on one side it's fake math and the
other side it's poor human behavior both
of which I'm empathetic to we lack
creative humility most of the things
that I make for myself and my businesses
I have a good ratio punch but a lot of
times I'm wrong my most successful
pieces of creative for my businesses and
myself have been things that I didn't
expect to be the most successful and
that lack of humility is real yo thank
you thank you for having me
yes got a little frustration out
I really want to help them do the right
thing yeah like why wouldn't I hey guys
how are you good how are you glad you're
here good to see you great to see you
glad you're here thanks for thanks for
doing much we were at early can one of
my first ones 2 A.M at the table that
was like that was a real rant
the same I've been debating for 15
years
reaching frequency brand position
it's relevance
[Music]
good afternoon everybody thank you uh so
much I'm just really excited a lot of
people in this room are here
I just want to thank everybody for
coming through I know there's 4 700
different lunches going on right now so
we are incredibly humbled that you're
with us
[Music]
things have been done in a certain way
up to now and we think that it's
one-sided it's a win on one side we're
always trying to create a win-win for
creators for the users of a platform for
the platform itself and for everybody to
join I am fast
value I do think people from free social
networks that have an ungodly amount of
human beings consuming and we talk about
a Charlie demilio or Logan Paul but
there is a very long tale of human
beings hundreds of thousands yes who
make hundreds of thousands of dollars a
year being influenced on any platforms
that cost them nothing I really don't
think it's as one-sided I think it's
more of a game of and than one-sided for
closer friends now
laughs
[Music]
awesome thank you everyone
um are you optimistic that decentralized
social networks have a future 100 I
genuinely believe it will happen but it
will take time you know friends from
Myspace those were two very early
indicators of where the world was going
but there was hundreds that failed
trying to do the same thing I fully
believe that it will happen I don't know
if it's this year I don't know if it's
40 years from now I don't know if it's
seven years from now but I think it's a
matter of time the downfalls are people
are going to be exposed to the Merit
they're going to have to drive it
because there is no algorithm there is
nothing else and so it'll be fun to see
how it works
please before you leave say hello to one
or two faces you don't know that is
always historically been the real Roi
from things of this so have the courage
to say hello to somebody that you don't
know because it's a safe kind ecosystem
so thank you have a great can could you
imagine if you could take your phone and
hit a button and a limousine would pick
you up on the spot I was literally in
the room when Uber was invented
[Music]
thank you